[موسيقى]
لذلك نرى اننا لمواجهه هذا التهديد الذاتي
يجب ان نجعل انظمتنا ذاتيه بدورها ونجعل
الالات تتعلم اتخاذ القرارات بسرعه كبيره
كي لا يضطر ان اشغلها لاتخاذ القرار
بنفسها لاننا عاده ما نعاني من الوقت
الكبير المستغرق لاتخاذ القرار النهائي
حيث ان سرعه القرار بالغه الاهميه لمضاهات
سرعه قرار الاله المسيره والتهديدات
المصاحبه لذلك
[موسيقى]
لدينا مجموعه عديده من البيانات حول
الانظمه التي كنا بصدد دراستها لرصد
التهديدات ولتتمكن من تحديد اي هدف ان كان
مسيره او طائره او طائرا او من طادا وهويه
اي تهديد نرصده في السماء اذ لا نريد ان
نربك المشغل بكميات مهوله من البيانات حول
اخطار ليست بتهديدات حقيقيه والذكاء
الاصطناعي يمنحونات تلك القدره لبناء
النظام الذاتي المناسب لاستخدامات المشغل
[موسيقى]
نحن نرى ان الذكاء الاصطناعي مهم جدا
لتسريع عمليه اتخاذ القرار كما اننا نعلم
ان هناك اشخاصا في هذا النظام وهذا العنصر
البشري موجود في اي عمليه لكن ان فكرنا في
كم تهديدات التي على مشغل النظام التعامل
معها ان لم يكن لديه دعم من الذكاء
الاصطناعي فانه سيخضع لضغط شديد من
المعلومات والمسؤوليات التي تقع على كاهله
[موسيقى]